les balles rebondissaient par milliers
sur les tables ce week end lors du
tournoi régional de
voisins-le-bretonneux et pour cause en
l'espace de quatre ans le tournoi
vicinaux a vu son nombre de participants
triplé passant de 100 à environ 300
joueurs venus de toute l'île de france
un succès qui permet d'attirer des
pointures tricolore comme alexis marc
haut de son neuvième joueur français il
a arrêté les compétitions individuelles
au niveau national mais garde le contact
avec les tournois on prépare un match je
montais en national la semaine prochaine
en par équipes
donc c'était pour pouvoir faire des
matches avant avant la semaine prochaine
le but quand même aujourd'hui c'est de
gagner la compétition s'est préparé la
semaine prochaine aussi de pouvoir
gagner le tournoi
ce week-end une quarantaine de joueurs
vis in what défendez leur chance parmi
eux un droitier plutôt discret se fait
plaisir autour de la table on agit
aujourd'hui donc dans le tout c'est
ribas et me faire plaisir parce que je
jouais déjà fort que moi et dans le
tableau bas c'est d'arriver le plus loin
possible
je jouais des joueurs un peu près à mon
niveau ou un peu plus fort et donc bas
et saidal plus impossible assis sur la
chaise d'arbitré entre ces matches
anthony deluise sortir a promis de sa
poule mais échouera en huitièmes de
finale
en revanche trois joueurs vie si noah se
sont hissés sur le podium ce week end
prochain rendez vous la coupe de double
des yvelines